we now have news that big banks are
starting to look at bitcoin-backed debt
disaster that's going to be hold on a
second
el salvador went ahead and said that
they're going to issue this
bitcoin-backed bond i saw your tweet
where you said it was worse than the
subprime debacle why do you think uh
it's worse than subprime you're talking
about bitcoin as collateral for a loan
and the problem with subprime mortgages
was that the real estate that was
collateralizing it could lose value okay
right and and so
when the lender if the borrower defaults
and the lender looks to the collateral
this house and now they go to sell it
well the price could be down so you're
saying just so people at home can pay
attention here so let's say a house is
uh we use these numbers a hundred
thousand dollars and in order to buy the
home uh i put down no money or five
percent put down five thousand dollars
and i borrowed ninety five thousand
dollars to buy the home right based on
the fact that the home is worth a
hundred thousand dollars and
historically the idea is that that house
if it's worth a hundred thousand dollars
today 20 years from now will be worth
more than a hundred thousand dollars the
problem is or if two years or three
years from now because you might fall
right away you might lose your job you
know right so you buy the house so the
idea is if though the house actually
isn't worth 100 000 because the market
had gotten too hot and people had gotten
loose with their lending requirements
now all of a sudden i actually lend you
not the 100 000 value of the house
you're gonna buy the house for two
hundred thousand you still put down five
thousand i lend you 195 grand and you
default when i go to liquidate the house
i can't sell for 200 grand i have to
sell it for 100 grand of what the actual
value is i'm underwater on the loan
because i wasn't able to do it well yeah
i mean now you're talking about a big
decline a 50 decline in real estate
which i'm just using an extreme example
but right that's rare right the problem
with bitcoin is a big drop let's say a
20 30 drop isn't rare all the time hold
on because this is really important i i
actually think i'm going to get you to
understand why bitcoin-backed loans are
very unique to the point where you may
go and participate ready
in a house uh situation if i gave you
that 195 000 loan and the house declined
whether it was five percent or 50
in order to liquidate it i have to sell
a house and if the market is declining
it is very very hard because it
accelerates like it did in the housing
crisis everyone was dumping houses
because there was so much uh inventory
in the market there weren't enough
buyers people were in a dire financial
situation and so it got worse and worse
and worse faster and faster tons of
large lenders got in a lot of trouble
very quickly we got the global financial
crisis
with bitcoin loans one of the things
that is very unique about them is if you
said to me hey i have 200 000 worth of
bitcoin you can only borrow on these
platforms up to let's say a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars against your 200
000 for the bitcoin so it's an over
collateralized loan now the value or the
advantage that bitcoin has compared to
your house is when the house price
starts to fall there's no mark to market
so it's hard to tell but you can feel it
in the market you can see comps and
stuff like that but you have to sell the
whole house to recruit your costs
with bitcoin it's a highly divisible
asset it can be uh denominated up to a
hundred million satoshi's and there's a
liquid market so what these lenders will
do is they'll say give me your two
hundred thousand dollars of bitcoin i'll
give you a 150 000 loan you go do
whatever you want with 150 000 uh a loan
i'm going to take your 200 000 bitcoin
if the price starts to fall i give you a
margin call i say hey you're now at 70
margin you have to cure the margin call
if you don't care yeah i
of the understand into the market so i
have to sell 200 000 i can sell a
thousand dollars at a time if i want it
and i can make sure that i will never
lose money on the loan because i can
always liquidate the over collateralized
uh uh
let me stop you so first of all yes
um
loaning against bitcoin is more similar
to loaning against stocks than loaning
against real estate mortgage because
mortgage loans uh you know yes
real estate it's not all identical and
yes if you have to foreclose there's a
whole process and then you got to put
the house on the market and you know you
could take a while to sell it
uh and but of course too when somebody
takes out a mortgage
you know they don't mark the house to
market every day you can't get a margin
call as long as you pay your mortgage
you don't lose your house but if you
leverage your stock portfolio they mark
the stocks to market every day
and if the stocks fall by a certain
amount you have a margin call you can't
meet it they start selling your stock
they don't sell all of it they sell
what's required right the same with
bitcoin the reason i think loaning
against bitcoin is inherently riskier
than loaning against stocks and let's
say you're loaning against non-dividend
paying stocks so the bar the owner is
not getting any income
is that i think bitcoin
is
more volatile correct then stocks so
more likely now obviously any individual
stock you know look at docusign today
down 33 overnight so if you were you had
you were on margin for that one stock
but i think brokerage firms when you
margin one individual stock that they
sometimes they they up the margin
requirements they're worried that they
could have a big move
um but i think
bitcoin is more prone
to
a
uh a big move okay but also here's what
you forget
let's assume
that there is a 30 40 drop in bitcoin
let's say 50 which happened last march
all right i i have an example i don't
want to say the company but i know a
business that had billions of dollars of
bitcoin backed loans out
on march 12th or march 18th whenever it
was and bitcoin fell 50
in one day they had zero loss of capital
yeah i mean
they're very fortunate at that time but
i i would imagine that let's say bitcoin
were to drop 50
in an environment where a lot of people
uh had
bitcoin loans and i think a lot of
people who have been hoteling bitcoin
are probably taking advantage of these
loans because a they don't want to sell
their bitcoin and pay tax they don't
live in puerto rico so they don't want
to sell their bitcoin and generate taxes
they also don't want to get off uh the
gravy train they think it's going to the
moon they don't want to miss out on all
the appreciation but they want to get
out of their parents basements they want
their own place there's also opportunity
opportunity cost of there's not many
other places to go in assets right you
can't go back to dollars because that's
obviously being depreciated gold is down
but my point is
my point my point is that
a lot of these people are borrowing
against their bitcoin and they're going
out and buying stuff right so they don't
they don't they don't necessarily have
money to meet a margin call if they get
it because they spent it on a car they
spent it on a vacation they barred
against some bitcoin so let's say you
get a big drop in the price of bitcoin
50
and now the margin calls go out and the
people like i don't have any money i
spent it okay well we got to liquidate
your bitcoin well everybody's getting
liquidated at once and where are all the
buyers all of a sudden you have this
massive liquidation into a fall mark
into a weak market maybe the exchange is
shut down maybe it's like oh you can't
even sell but and we have this happening
this isn't hypothetical right we had
this happen in march of last year what
you're saying it has something you may
not beat me they may be way more
leveraged now than there was then
there's less leverage than uh there
there used to be liquidity yeah but
there was a 50 drawdown which i think is
a fair argument to say hey if a bunch of
people are doing this and then there's a
mass liquidation right obviously the
price falls drastically my only point is
that bitcoin is the single best
collateral for the lender to take
for a loan why is that the best
because even in your example of stocks i
have to sell the full stock so if an
apple no you have to sell a full share
but but yeah
but but that's so small money but you
don't have to sell the full
share of bitcoin in order to continue to
protect the
so a share of stock might be ten dollars
a share fifty dollars a share i mean
people when people are borrowing fifty
thousand dollars a hundred thousand
dollars
i mean so at ten dollars how many shares
do i have to sell i have to sell
was it five yeah yeah there's the amount
of money
the fact that you can't break a share
down into a half a share is ridiculous
because that's such a tiny amount of
money that it doesn't matter depends on
the price of the share
no you could sell if if i buy if i
margin a thousand shares you could sell
99 999 of those shares you know if you
instead of 999 and a half